and the linen consultant I'm often asked
to go between many various subjects so
it might be in exercise science ecology
drug calculations in nursing have
statistics in psychology and to have a
single frame with a single platform that
can answer queries across the board
views incredibly useful I'm a learning
consultant at edith cowan university and
also the founder of on software startup
as a learning consultant at ECU i
provide support across the various
schools as part of my startup i'm
looking to take some of those ideas in
support that i provide and capture them
in a CDF or an interactive application
and perhaps they can be useful elsewhere
so usable from language in teaching
research and in innovation in teaching
I'm often required to work across
different schools so I can provide
assistance in exercise science in
providing some data analysis in sport
science it might be drug calculations in
nursing or perhaps are statistics in
psychology a little bit of discrete
mathematics engineering differential
equations so whole smorgasbord of stem
areas and Wolfram language has a lot of
inbuilt knowledge that I can tap into it
so kind of a jack-of-all-trades that the
learning consultant probably the top
three features of the Wolfram language
that I use on a daily basis especially
the built in knowledge so as I mentioned
every learning consultant I have to work
across many different schools and so you
need that wide functionality the second
aspect of the Wolfram language that I
enjoy daily is the high-level nature of
the programming language there's many
different paradigms with the language
and the naming of the functions very
well chosen it's intuitive language so
you can start from very small programs
to examples up to building quite
sophisticated systems the third aspect
of the Wolfram language that I think is
important is it allows you to take any
ideas any teaching innovations and
research findings and communicate them
to the wider world in a very seamless
way
you have access to very latest
algorithms so for example a deep
learning in neural networks you can show
to students some of the cutting-edge
research in a very intuitive and
immediate way the Wolfram language is
very versatile so you can create an
interface and that allows you to take
your data
take your models send it down to the
center let the center do it stuff
overnight get it to send back to you and
you have a look at the results the next
day so you can do this all in a single
boat so it's almost one-click super
confusing Clinton's just another example
of a pipeline which makes more from
language very power